let's think about the different use
cases for credit default swap so let's
say that I have some company over here
and it's been it's given a double B
credit rating and this rating of course
comes from a credit rating agency credit
rating agency sometimes called a ratings
agency or a rating agency I've seen at
every different way so this would be
like Moody's or Standard & Poor's or
whatever else and they say they look at
this company and they look at its
business they look at its balance sheet
they say okay it's not super safe but
it's not super risky either we give it a
double B rating and let's say that
there's an investor over here who wants
to lend money to this company so he
might lend them some money and get some
interest in return get some interest in
return but this investor doesn't like
this this level of safety he wants to
get he wants to make sure that he's made
whole even if this company goes out of
business so he can go to a writer of a
credit default swap and the most famous
of those credit default swap writers is
or was AIG and he'll say hey IG I'm
going to pay you a little bit every year
you can view that as an insurance
premium and in exchange you are
essentially going to insure you're going
to insure me in the case of a default by
this company insurance and what we
already said it's a little bit shady
because a it was not regulated like
insurance so AIG did not have to set
anything aside and what was powerful
here for AIG is that the rating agencies
continue to give AIG a very high rating
so let's say it had a double-a rating so
despite the fact that it kept taking on
all of these liabilities the credit
rating agency says hey we'll still give
you a double-a so they were able to use
this double-a rating to keep writing
these contracts to keep writing
insurance not setting anything aside and
essentially just getting almost you
could view it free money with eventually
having to pay the piper eventually now
this is one scenario another scenario is
maybe an investment bank creates some
type of special-purpose entity or some
collateralized debt obligation right
over here and what they could they have
their different tranches and maybe for
their for the senior tranche over here
just so that they can sell them to
pension funds
who can only buy Double A rated Det
pension funds the investment bank goes
to AIG and says hey can this entity
right over here by credit default swaps
can get can we enter into credit default
swap agreements on you so that in case
any of this stuff were to default you
will also ensure that and once we do
that then a rating agency so this is a
security this is the senior tranche of a
credit of a collateralized debt
obligation now the senior tranche and
now that that senior tranche is
essentially insured by AIG a credit
rating agencies credit rating agency
once again will assign this a double-a
rating even though this thing might be
made up of a bunch of subprime mortgages
and all of the rest although it is the
senior tranche so it'll get be made
whole first but now pension funds can
buy this type of thing the last use case
is maybe you have a hedge fund out here
hedge fund out here who it doesn't want
to lend anybody any money but it's
convinced that about a whole bunch of
these companies maybe this company over
here or maybe this company over here
that has a that has some other ratings
so this is another company this hedge
fund is convinced that these companies
aren't are going to default on their
debt that there's going to be a credit
crisis of some kind well then this hedge
fund can enter into credit default swap
agreements could enter into credit
default swap agreements to essentially
get insurance but not having anything to
insure it's like getting car insurance
on someone else's on someone else's
driving or someone else's car and you
kind of are starting to hope that they
have to have a car accident because now
if this guy has a credit default swap on
company on this company right over here
despite the fact that they didn't lend
out to them the hedge fund is going to
pay a little bit every year and get the
insurance and the they're essentially
going to hope that this company goes out
of business because if it does then
they're going to get the insurance
payment they're going to get the same
payment that this investor would have
but they would have never had to lend
the money so you could use it as a side
bet you could use it as a way of making
lower rated securities all of a sudden
acceptable to pension funds or you could
use it as a straight-up way of insuring
debt
you're lending to someone else